they just also another thing of course
they're banning trump from everything
youtube's and twitter and
they've now officially banned him from
grindr this article says he's
trying to not make a grinder account
that's not fair that is
not fair right that's crossing the line
this is too much
yeah the tech companies are it's too
much dude
i mean he is a little nuts and he did
encourage those people to run in there
uh but it's a little much when you just
take him off everything now they're just
doing let him be on shopify yeah i mean
he's got i mean grinder how can you make
a political statement on grindr let the
guy put his abs up in his profile
if trump gets a bunch of gay guys to
storm the capital with their shirts off
that's [ __ ] hilarious yeah that would
be yeah i mean
that's let's make that happen somehow
let's do it let him go on grindr yes
dude gaze for trump has got like over a
million followers
dude let's just tell gay people that
there's gonna be
one last liza minnelli impersonation
show in the capitol and that [ __ ]
thing will get stormed
stormed yeah hundred percent yeah
madonna's final final [ __ ]
performance before we kill her
that thing will be crawling with gays
yanni how was the chappelle rogan show
last night
the chipotle uh chappelle is so funny
it's
it's actually and i think he's even
funnier when it's like a smaller
venue and like he's like it's not a spec
the guy is so
funny and good at stand up it's actually
hard to believe how funny he is it's
like
there's no point for any of us to do
stand-up anymore because we're just
doing shows that he can't be at
right just because they don't have
chappelle
and rogan by the way is excellent dude
he was also
incredible they were all incredible and
mo crushed
mo was really funny i think i think both
chapel and rogan suck
yeah and part of why is because i'm sick
of these [ __ ]
legendary people i think our job is to
put them all in a [ __ ] grave
and there's nothing worse than by
sucking their [ __ ] every day which is
what we do
rappers tear other rappers down and we
better start doing that
otherwise these people are never going
to leave we're never going to get any
[ __ ] work now let me just cut timmy
off that's timmy
seventh rogan appearance after the first
one he was like
yes mr rogan i am available
let me tell you what i would have said
after my first drug advance right i
would have said
seeing people that are so talented
is amazing to me and just but now i'm
just like let's see we got it we got to
put them all in the grave yeah